A latch tool, also called a Tappet tool,
is just a machine needle with a handle.
It has a number of different
uses to manually form stitches.
Most commonly, it's used to reverse
stitches, turning knit
stitches into Purl stitches.
Notice how the Purl bump is showing
against the knit stitches in this example.
To reform an existing stitch,
push the tool into a stitch below the one
that's currently in work on a needle.
Drop the stitch off
the needle and un-ravel it.
Forming a ladder.
Use the tool to pick up each ladder,
forming new stitches.
To create a column of reformed
stitches, drop a single stitch.
Pick up each ladder, forming new stitches.
When the last strand has been knit,
rehang the stitch on the needle.
Now you have a column
of reformed stitches.
This can be done across a row
for a turning row or a manually
formed decorative Purl row.
Another use of the latch
tool is for binding off.
Knit the last row of your knitting
at the loosest tension or
manually knit a loose row.
Slip the first stitch off the needle
and place it on the tool
behind the latch of the tool.
Slip the adjacent stitch to the tool
in the hook on the tool.
Purl the second stitch through the first.
This is called a stitch
through stitch Bindoff.
This method is fast, but it may
not be as stretchy as you need.
Please try other bind off
methods in addition to this one.
Any time you use a latch tool,
remember you're positioning a needle
in the opposite direction
of the needle on the needle bed.
If you reform stitches,
they will be facing the opposite way.
Think about knit and Purl stitches,
as in hand knitting.